we are joined now by dr ashish jaw dean
of brown university school of public
health it's always good to see you dr
john i want to
focus on what appeared to be good news
about the schools
it doesn't seem at this point that they
are the super spreaders that people
thought they could be
do you feel that too are you more
optimistic that schools can reopen
safely
yeah good morning gail thanks for having
me on you know i am more optimistic i
think we are learning as schools are
opening
uh especially the younger grades under
you know k through 5
look pretty safe in most communities
older high school i think you still have
to be a bit more careful mask wearing
some level of testing would be helpful
everywhere but i'm becoming more
optimistic that we've got to try to get
kids back in school
yeah i've heard you say there's a high
cost of keeping kids learning remotely
what does that cost
yeah the cost of keeping kids learning
remotely is really quite substantial we
know it widens achievement gaps
we know it's causing a lot of mental
health issues for kids
you know kids are not born to be zooming
into class
all day every day yeah it's one thing to
do it in for a few days
but to do it for an extended period of
time it's really harmful yeah but we
keep hearing covet cases
on the rise again in 37 states what can
we do what should we be doing to stop
the spread dr fauci says
we're not careful we're going to have a
very rough winter and another big
outbreak
what to do dr shaw yeah dr fauci is
right so here are the things right
first of all everybody's got to be
wearing masks when they're outside their
home
can we say that dr shaw how many
freaking times can we say
wear your mask i'm serious
i know and a lot of folks are still not
doing it and i'm saying please
do it so we can get kids back in i
really think bars
and a lot of indoor dining is very risky
a lot of people are starting to have
house parties and gatherings
look your home doesn't make you immune
to the virus so being careful being
thoughtful it's how we get
through this pandemic we talk about
wearing masks you know the president is
back on the road he's in florida they
said they passed out masks but people
weren't wearing them i don't know what
how what good that does if you're not
going to wear the mask he says that he
is immune
and he feels powerful is this the
message to send at this particular time
and let's talk about immunity what that
really means
yeah gail i think unfortunately it is
not the right message first of all we
don't know if the president is immune we
are seeing
some number of reinfections thankfully
not very many but some people are
getting re-infected
and second he's the president of the
united states he should be sending a
very clear symbol
uh and signal to the american people
about the importance of wearing mass
he's not doing that and that is really
unfortunate also as the president of the
united states he's getting a different
type of treatment too listen as it
should be as president of the united
states
he should get the best possible
treatment that is available
in the world so no one is faulting that
but he is getting a different kind of
treatment than most people get
true absolutely i mean the regeneron
therapy the antibody therapy he got
that's not accessible to most people
obviously world class care at walter
reed
the president got great care and i think
that's right but the point is
most americans can't get that he says
that he the president
trump's doctor said he's no longer
infectious he tested negative
for cons consecutive days using an
antigen test
is that good enough
the answer is this is unfortunate and
it's confused yeah you know gail this is
confusing because the anagen test is not
good enough it's not what it was
designed for
dr conley knows that my sense my guess
we don't know because he they haven't
been clear is that he's still pcr
positive
it's entirely possible the president is
no longer infectious but we'd like to
get the full information
and the anagen test doesn't get us there
all right and one more time
should i wear a mask or not wear a mask
i'm confused
gail please wear a mask it's good for
you it's good for everybody else
message received dr ashish jaw thank you
very much